acting Attorney General Sally Yates
decided to defy the White House and
refuse to defend new travel restrictions
targeting seven muslim-majority
countries Donald Trump immediately fired
her Yates said late last night that the
Justice Department would not be
defending the order against court
challenges saying that she did not
believe it would be consistent with the
institution's solemn obligation to
always seek justice and stand for
whatever is right Yates was an appointee
of President Barack Obama choose of
course by all indications just days away
from being replaced as attorney general
by jeff Sessions but after doing this
she was immediately fired by Donald
Trump sort of bringing the I don't know
apprentice reality show to the White
House to the real world remember the
White House doesn't decide what's legal
and here's the amazing thing when Sally
Yates was confirmed Trump's incoming
attorney general jeff Sessions seem to
want confirmation from Yates that she
wasn't just going to rubber-stamp
anything the president obama did that
she would actually evaluate the legality
check out this exchange and think about
how ironic this is now with the question
or jeff Sessions incoming a secretary of
state you have to watch out because
people be asking you to do things you
need to just need to say no about do you
think the Attorney General has a
responsibility to say no to the
president if he asked for something
that's improper a lot of people have
defended the Lynch nomination for
example by saying well he appoints
somebody who's going to execute his
views what's wrong with that about to
view the president wants to execute our
unlawful should the Attorney General or
the Deputy Attorney General say no
senator I believe that the Attorney
General or the Deputy Attorney General
has an obligation to follow the law and
the Constitution and to give their
independent legal advice to the
president some Trump ians are cheering
the firing saying hey Sally Yates wasn't
doing her job because she should just be
doing what the president wants the job
description
to prosecute and conduct all suits in
the Supreme Court in which the United
States shall be concerned and to give
his or her advice and opinion upon
questions of law when required by the
President of the United States or when
requested by the heads of any Department
that means part of her job is you
ascertain the legality of what it is
that the president wants to do this also
wasn't just Sally eight saying hey you
know what I'm just going to unilaterally
act and not defend it we had multiple
courts that stayed part of Donald
Trump's order her job is defend the
Constitution she sees the Constitution
being at odds with the order from Donald
Trump if you want an attorney general
that just agrees with the president
basically a rubber stamp you don't
actually need an attorney general it's
kind of reminding everyone of the
Saturday night Massacre when President
Nixon fired special prosecutor Archibald
Cox right for how he handled the
Watergate investigation and wanting to
subpoena those tapes I mean I don't know
if there's a direct correlation there
but it's clear that many sort of
defiance any sort of dissent will not be
allowed in the Trump administration
that's the big picture I want to point
to the firing in and of itself she was
going to be gone in days it's really not
the biggest field the big dealers were
very quickly moving towards
authoritarianism and beyond as numerous
experts have weighed in I did a story
about that yesterday we've got total
disdain for dissenting media the
silencing of science right the EPA
climate science information now a new
demand for all climate data to be
pre-cleared with with politicians in the
administration before publishing removal
and criticism of elements of the legal
system that don't agree with you a
desire to have total control over media
and and the judicial system and over the
elected officials that you will call out
on Twitter if they don't do what you
want this is rapidly moving in a
dangerously at or authoritarian
direction whatever you think about Sally
Yates she's not the issue here right she
had her days were quite literally
numbered at this point this is about the
broader direction of the country and the
attempt to reduce separation of powers
and checks and balances